Je me souviens d'un Procureur qui m'a dit,
il y a quelque temps, que la Justice
était toujours trop dure
pour soi-même et toujours
trop laxiste pour les autres.
Il y a beaucoup de préjugés sur notre Justice.
Ce n’est pas une Justice laxiste.
C'est une Justice qui,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et surtout
il y a quelques années,
était profondément
en souffrance par manque de moyens
et depuis cinq ans maintenant on réarme la Justice,
on lui redonne des moyens pour être plus rapide.
Parce qu'un des principaux reproches
qui est fait à la Justice française,
c'est qu'elle n'est pas assez rapide.
Ce texte, il reprend les conclusions
des Etats généraux de la Justice.
Sur l'ensemble du quinquennat,
ça va être 7,5 milliards
supplémentaires cumulés.
C'est énorme, c'est inédit et ça,
ça va nous permettre d'aller plus vite,
de mettre en place un certain nombre de choses
qui permettront d'avoir une Justice
encore plus proche des citoyens.
Et au-delà de ça,
c'est surtout du recrutement.
Plus 10000 recrutements, ce n'est pas rien.
Et puis aussi les moyens technologiques,
il ne faut pas les oublier.
Aujourd’hui, sonoriser un lieu,
mettre des caméras dans un lieu,
c'est déjà possible.
Dans notre texte,
on va rendre possible
des nouvelles techniques d'enquête
parce que les voyous
et les bandits ont aussi beaucoup évolué
et ils détournent complètement aujourd'hui
ces moyens qu’avaient la police à disposition.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
nos pauvres policiers
essayent de poser des balises
sous les voitures et autres
au risque de se faire choper.
Il faut qu'on donne les moyens vraiment
à nos forces de l'ordre de pouvoir lutter
contre les grands délinquants.
On a mis des garanties plus fortes
que sur les anciennes techniques
d'enquêtes spéciales, qui vraiment,
nous éloignent très, très largement
de ce que certains ont dénoncé
comme étant “Big Brother”.
Évidemment, tout le monde ne verra pas
son téléphone susceptible
d'être déclenché à distance.
Ça concerne des affaires
qui sont des affaires de grand banditisme,
de criminalité organisée et de terrorisme.
On n'est pas du tout sur des écoutes de masse.
Depuis 30 ans, 40 ans,
notre système judiciaire
est complètement à l'abandon
et, vraiment, souffre dans tous les domaines.
La Justice dans ce pays était la variable d'ajustement.
C'est-à-dire que quand on devait faire des économies,
on se disait : “allez, on ne met pas un centime de plus
dans le budget de la Justice”.
C'est tout le contraire qu'on a fait depuis six ans
et on va continuer encore pendant
les quatre années qui viennent.